[Musique]
des verts comme foudroyé par des jets de
peinture des stries de couleur
hypnotisante
ou encore cette illusion de vaguelettes
de sable entre peinture et sculpture une
soixantaine d'oeuvres joue sur la
lumière et la matière et interpelle le
spectateur
je suis très surpris par là la qualité
impression ça ça renvoie sur nous de
lumière de matières et l'arc était
vraiment élevé à une dimension j'ai
jamais rencontrée dans une exposition
sur le vitrail tout en s'appuyant sur
des techniques dernier cri
l'art du vitrail revient aujourd'hui à
ses origines celle de la représentation
des êtres et des objets comme cet enfant
qu'on dirait tiré d'une bande dessinée
on voit que l'artiste a fait de grands
personnages décidé comme finalement
dessinée au moyen âge aussi un vrai
retour de cet esprit qui raconte une
histoire à travers des dessins à travers
des personnages un peu comme une bande
dessinée
ce retour à la figuration s'est opérée
en 2015 avec comme référence le vitrail
du millénaire de la cathédrale de
strasbourg
d'où le choix de 2015 comme point de
départ de ce panorama du vitrail
contemporain
un art qui jouit aujourd'hui d'une
liberté totale à dire un renouveau du
vitrail extraordinaire de très
nombreuses commandes publiques dans de
très grands édifices des édifices
prestigieux et les artistes s'en donnent
un peu à coeur joie pour faire des
propositions nouvelles intéressantes
diversifié avec des matériaux nouveaux
vous avez derrière moi par exemple ce
gros vers ce grand vitrail qui est fait
avec comme un grand mur de verre un mur
de plusieurs verts en forme de u temps
et imbriqués les uns dans les autres
toutes ces oeuvres sont des répliques de
vitraux créés pour l'exposition ou des
prototypes comme celui ci qui sera
bientôt installée dans la cathédrale de
chartres
un vitrail comme un iris duquel émane
une lumière ruisselante un vitrail comme
un soleil bleu